foreign
you were born this way I've never read
anything like the script before Marin
she's just so unique she wants to
connect but is having a hard time doing
so and then you find out why
Marin she's a girl she's like 18. and
she is in the midst of being that but
also tries to hold very strongly on what
she has lost that's how this works how
well works this whatever this is we all
feel like Outsiders when we're growing
up I think everybody feels like that
it's a very Universal thing though to
feel misunderstood you know I'm thinking
of a bad person
all I think is that I love you it was a
joy working with Taylor I was open for
anything willing to try new things in
scenes when I and they started to talk
about the cast I said I think Taylor is
the only one who could do it she really
felt perfect for playing Marion I'll fix
some dinner Force she just brings
herself and that's very true aspect of
it you can read her thoughts in the
camera very beautifully
I just try to follow my instincts and
that usually leads me into very strange
places which is good because now I'm not
fighting it anymore I'm relaxing into
the strangeness of life
[Music]